ready to do this good to see you great
to see you
thanks for coming out man I appreciate
it a beautiful place chef thank you man
excited to talk to you I don't know how
many times we how many conversations
we've had but it's gotta be I don't know
four or five six or something like that
and each one of them for me start out
the same way which is like where are we
gonna go yeah I don't know but we'll
figure it out it's really good I mean
the first thing is that I wanted to know
a little bit more about is is is how
this adventure that you're having with
the podcast is going for you and
evolving it's really cool I've I've
watched it grow and I've watched it
evolve and I've watched you take risks
and try new things and it's been really
cool and it's it's exciting to see it
connecting with audiences like I feel
proud you know I want it I want to just
say out loud again thank you because
what happened was you you said Mike I'd
like to get you on the podcast and I
said I think I know what a podcast is
but and so it was meant to be a good
conversation is how you you know sold it
to me if you will and we had a great
conversation on this was like it was a
long time had to be I don't know at
least three years ago I think yeah it
what for sure it must have been and I
loved it
and I saw what you were doing and I got
to tell my story and not that my story
matters but it was it was it was
wonderful to be able to talk in depth in
a real conversation about things that
really matter to me and I thought I'd
like to give that gift to other people
yeah
and now you're doing it I mean I think I
even said to you after that like you
should have pie I mean you said the
media is perfect for you it is you know
what what happened for me for a long
time is that so as a licensed
psychologist who I work with and the
nature of what we talk about is
privileged and so I don't own I don't
own the rights to any of that the client
does the patient if you will and I don't
call them patients I don't you know
right like they're they're extraordinary
humans and so
the word patience has a funny little
term to our baggage with it but so that
was all kept in like this working
laboratory very much a sanctuary type
experience in relationship and then so
the thought of being able to have a
public conversation was never a thought
never a thought right and until you said
no no like why don't you get some of
your friends friends why don't you know
don't ask your clients well and also
it's just your approach it's the way you
ask questions it's your curiosity and
it's the ideas that percolate out of
those conversations that are applicable
in a broad way it doesn't have to be a
patient you know doctor no it can't it
can't be right now okay and I hope that
people that come on finding mastery
don't feel like that but I will say that
people walk away saying two things they
say that was intense
yeah and I feel a little better because
of it you know it's a lot of like no
one's ever asked me that question before
but I hear I have folks on your podcast
say the same thing like good probably
not to the extent they they they say it
to you and what's funny is that is that
I mean we must have we have so much
overlap in our in our guest pool like
there's at least a dozen people that
there's been multiple occasions where
somebody came right from your show and
came to me and vice versa
it's the same day twice yes sure it's
happened twice and I always think to
myself like the competitive pardon me
like damn it rich I think it was I think
Anthony Irvine came here right after
doing yours and I was like oh he's gonna
be tired and Michael just put him
through that but I love listening to
your your like because what you do is
similar but it's very different and I'm
like oh man why didn't I think of that
why didn't I think of that question and
you get to go so deep with these people
like you're very gifted at it well thank
you and I would say where you take
clients or clients where you take folks
is like so organic and so real that that
attraction pays dividends for listeners
and as a let's call it um and what kind
of listener am i I've got like at least
three lenses when I listen to others
podcasts including yours one is like I'm
a learner I just want to learn another
is as a trained psychologist like to see
the depth and the nature and the
stuttering and the hesitations or the
exuberance to go somewhere and then the
the texture of those responses and then
as like this quasi professional like the
the linking of questions and the linking
of thoughts so your organic nature like
what's happening right now is right
every you're gonna make me
self-conscious now oh yeah no no it's
not but I've actually had to work I
would say almost my entire adult life
for sure and it probably goes back to
earlier to extract judgment and to what
does that mean
like to not not judge to not be critical
and I think there's a you know there's a
real thought that to become great at
something you need to be critical I'm
not sure that I would ever now that what
I've come to learn would prescribe that
that is a path and but there's
discernment discernment is different
yeah for sure but that thought like that
I'm gonna put you under some sort of
right something I'm not critical of
myself nor nor you like but I'm really
curious about the intensity the
curiosity the tone like where are you
gonna take the conversation what how am
I gonna respond and so anyways you know
what I wanted to ask you I want you to
ask you about so we both had Alex and
all Don and like I think he's one of the
most significant minds in sport right
now and so I'd love to I'd love to ask
you what I our set up was different so I
had him in a live environment and so it
was yeah you were like at USC in front
of a huge auditorium de boville yeah it
was um it was amazing and so but it's a
different nature when that's a public
conversation you know there's a little
bit of a fishbowl experience and I'd
love to learn and maybe we can swap
notes here is what you learned and then
you know I'd love to share that as well
my perspective well I mean the first
thing I would say is that I agree with
you I think he's one of the most
brilliant athletes walking planet Earth
right now I mean what he's capable of
doing is boggles the mind and I just
think his proficiency and his his
mastery to use your word
is on a level that you know few athletes
are capable of achieving like in a
scenario in which the risks and the you
know could not be higher right it's just
unbelievable what he's able to do and I
think what I took away from him
well a couple things I mean first of all
you know speaking of ego is the enemy
there's a there's a tremendous
groundedness to him and humility that I
would imagine must be you know must be
due to parenting and the way he was
raised because you know you would expect
somebody of that stature to carry
themselves a little bit differently so I
found that to be very impressive amongst
you know his many qualities but I think
that's stuck with me the most and I
think the other thing was his ability to
to exercise that discernment so that he
can be focused on the things that are
most important to him right in a world
in which he's getting pulled in a
million different directions he has the
strength and the will to turn that
channel down so that he can do what he's
here to do yeah very cool I think he for
me he represented all of that and I
found it to be there's one other thing
his ability to trust himself mm-hmm when
he when if he does make mistakes it's
not like he's mistake free but when he
makes mistakes
his ability to adjust and his ability to
trust himself to adjust in a very highly
consequential environment is like no
other right there's only handfuls of
people and handfuls of environments work
forces if you will that the that that is
it's that intense and I spent some time
brief amount of time I always have such
a high regard for people that put their
lives on the line for other people's
well-being and I spent some time on in
the on the USS Truman and it was a dip
in and dip out it's one of the beautiful
aircraft carriers or very intense
aircraft carriers you know the American
Navy and so it's the most dangerous
place to work is on the air deck
and when I was talking to it was the XO
or was it Co XO who was one of the two
heads of the USS Truman he was a former
pilot and the way he described to me his
craft he says has you've ever been in a
car accident and I said yeah and he said
do you remember the adrenaline happened
I said oh yeah like there's a lot have
you been in one before no you have not
other than like a fender bender yeah
okay it was there adrenaline rush there
was probably what was that easily you
know that the adrenaline rush is easily
triggered yes so he said so let's say
that somebody hasn't had that experience
as a car crash if you can recall what he
was trying to conjure up the most
intense adrenaline rush you've ever had
he says his left leg would shake and
here's the story he shared with me and
I'm gonna map this back to Alex in just
a second is that he was this is how he
was trying to describe his the danger in
his job and the way it feels is that he
was driving he and his family they
loaded up a rig and the truck and a
fifth wheel is that we call it like it
was they were moving and he was taking
some stuff to the new destination and it
was tired and he's a tough guy he says
and he's kind of trying to grind out the
fatigue and he starts to drift out of
his Lane and he comes back to and
there's a semi screaming his horn coming
the other direction so he swerves just a
little bit I think he I can't remember
if it was ice or not I can't remember
that part of the story but it's like he
felt very out of control in this moment
and he's like okay I got it I got it I
got it
and then all of a sudden his fifth wheel
started to parallel well with his car so
it was like a what do you call that like
a jackknifed hydroplane yeah yeah so he
was hydroplane but the back the back rig
if you will was now parallel to his
trike so he makes this kind of America
amazing adjustment and his truck and
fifth wheel straightened out and the the
rig just barely misses him as the
dramatic story should end right and he
pulls off to the side and he said if you
can imagine what that was like
my legs were shaking my arms were
trembling I wasn't breathing during that
time but it was amazing and I was
frightened and he said that's what it's
like every time I try to land on an
aircraft carrier Wow
so that intensity will get Alex killed
so that's not what alex has and so when
we think about dangerous risk-takers
dangerous environments risk takers
that's not the same environment that
Alex lives in that's not his internal
system his internal system as I've come
to understand from many of these folks
is that there's a quietness with a deep
trust that I know how to get myself out
of a jam I know how to adjust the
difficult moments even when the
consequences potentially limb or life
and I loved ant at the same time I
thought it was one of the hardest
interviews or conversations I was it why
because his nickname is no big deal yeah
so Alex what's it like to have you know
sort of deflecting and yeah your thumb
and middle finger in in a hole and
you're dangling from 2,000 feet and
you've lost your footing on your you
know it was cool it's funny because it's
arguably the most extreme amongst the
extreme sports but it isn't and it's
like you said it's not an adrenaline
boosting thing it's all it's it's quite
the opposite he has to you know he has
to get himself into this incredible
almost like a trance-like state of
extreme focus and calmness and in terms
of like intuition my sense is that he's
just a highly integrated human being
like he knows how he tooks he knows why
he tooks and I don't know what process
he undertook to understand himself on
such a deep level but I think that is
foundational and and one of the keys to
his success and I think you know in
terms of speaking about that more
broadly and I'm interested in what you
think about this look you're in the
business of talking about peak
performance everybody wants to be a peak
performer regardless of whether you're
sitting in a cubicle or you're an
athlete or whatever
I don't know if everyone does like a but
there but they're interested in peak
performance right how can i how can i
all can i see better and at the same
time I think there's like this cynical
tone as well that takes place like okay
peak performance like I get both of
those mm-hmm
and I think I want to hear what you why
you think everyone wants it because my
experience is that most people nod their
head that they want to be better but
don't want to do the work mm-hmm and so
that's why you know that's why all these
life hacks are so popular yeah but the
idea behind the life hack is you know on
some on some level about optimization I
suppose yeah so everyone's looking to
you know let I see what they want to do
it the easy way and so to bring it back
around like the point that I was making
is is you know when you look at someone
like Alex he's he's able to optimize on
such a high level because of that
profound level of self understanding
that he has right and that's the part
people don't want to do they want to
skip that part
the self-discovery yeah because there is
no there's don't get me wound up right
you know he's like I want to unleash you
on this point because I think it's super
important I think people look at this
and they either don't understand what
that means or they find it inconvenient
or or unnecessary like they just want to
get to the sexy part but that's where
the work is and when you see somebody
who is so self actualized as Alex the
proof is in the pudding because his
ability to execute on what he cares
about is a direct function of that
integration process yes
I mean I'm shaking my head yes and I
love that I love this phrase that
someone gave us this my wife and I this
thought early on which was parenting is
inconvenient and super in communion
super inconvenient yeah it doesn't mean
that that that was that's not a bad
thought that is like to do parenting
well you're gonna have to maybe leave
places that you want to be because you
say to your son or daughter whomever
like hey the behavior that you're
Demming that you're that you're
it's not okay and if it continues we're
gonna have to leave Disneyland even
though you want to be there what or you
or this party that you're at or this see
what a and if you the inconvenient being
inconvenience not by the the human that
you're raising but by the axe that
sometimes our untimely and that's the
hard work that's what actually creates
the beautiful bonds between children
adults is the ability for them to trust
like okay they have my best interests
even though it's not easy now to live
through and you said it was inconvenient
for people or it is inconvenient to do
the long difficult journey of
self-discovery oh yeah it's hard right
that's hard to be honest it's hard to do
that alone work nobody can give you
wisdom yeah and I don't know that I ever
would have done it had my back not been
up against the wall you know pain has
always been my motivator to really look
inward and make changes so I've been
asked this question to people lately and
I don't know if it's a fair question and
I'd look I'd like to get your thoughts
on it love to win or hate to lose and if
they were spaced and choose a third
option would you choose a third option
and or would you just say oh yeah it's
this one out of those two I would choose
a third option for me it's never about
winning or not losing it's just a
function of whether I lived up to what I
believed to be my potential like did I
do my best
did I put everything into trying to
achieve a certain result and then so
that's that's why I thought I think it's
not a fair question and that being said
is the process to better understand what
is possible for anybody for oneself or
for somebody else is difficult like that
that takes discernment that takes deep
thinking to think about like and this is
I think this might be one of the most
loving thing we can do for another human
is to think deeply about what is
possible have a conversation with that
person calibrate that conversation nod
our heads to it once we get the fabric
in the texture of that that thought
aligned and then commit
to helping supporting and challenging
that person through and if we're left
alone to do it it's it's really hard
that's why I don't I haven't seen anyone
that does it alone right but back to the
thought hate to lose hate to lose love
to win almost 95% of people that asked
that question to they whether they think
that they are on the right path or not
no no no let me not say it that way that
sounds almost crude 95 percent was
saying hate to lose and then given a
little bit more space true really that
yeah yes but because but that what
spurred me on that is your thought which
is I had to come from pain so they the
pain of losing which if we map it on the
brain there's no loss center of the
brain there's grief there's like you
know there's there's no the redundancies
in the brain are minimized because it's
this amazing super power computer that
we don't even know really how it works
but the thought that there's a center
for losing a Super Bowl or losing a an
ultra event there's no center in the
brain for that it is mapped over grief
right so most people grief is so hard
for people and then when they so that
when they go put their butt on the line
and go for it in a competitive
environment or a vulnerable environment
and they come up short it's feels like
grief and that's hard
and so hating to feel grief is the
response that's how I decode that
thought like an avoidance strategy yeah
like I hate it so much I'll do whatever
it takes to relieve myself from him and
I'm not sure that that's a beautiful way
to do you know the process yeah no I
don't think so I don't think so so when
you sit down with you know somebody that
you're working with like how do you
begin to to figure this out and find a
different through line to connect with
that person to perhaps provide a
foundation for a healthier motivation
well we tried to get clear the first
part is that not first part but just the
value to discovery process now look
let's just not our head that the initial
part you're asking me like what I'm not
doing my craft is that right right as a
sports psychologist or performance
ideologist so the initial so the way
I've structured it is that we spend
eight hours together that's a long day
mm-hmm by the end of the day we're
exhausted
we both are tired because we're working
relentlessly towards insight and then at
the end of those eight hours if we are
so fortunate to have some insight about
what makes this the person that I'm
working with who are they and what makes
them work if you will what are they
driven by and driven toward and then if
we can get a handful of insights
together then we can set up and design a
way to train one's mind and organize
one's life for optimizing right okay so
that deep deep work is really like who
are you what are you driven by what are
you driven toward and then what do you
imagine is possible and so that but in
order to really get to the heart of that
it's not just a function of like oh what
drives you I want to win the Super Bowl
or I want to win an Olympic gold medal
yeah okay but is that really what's
driving them like you have to get
beneath that weight well it's like yeah
this like what's the strategy like how
do you begin to pull those layers back
and get to the heart of who somebody
really is you know it's a fun part that
I don't ever talk about is that okay I
want to kind of link two things together
one is I was on a recent podcast I'll
keep it nameless and I got really fiery
during the conversation and I said to
the interviewer I said you know what it
feels like to be on this side of the
conversation it feels like you've
grabbed me by my ankles you've tried to
wrestle me to get me upside down and
shake out whatever you think is in my
head you know like trying to get the
lint and the coins that come from my
pockets and whatever thoughts you know
that could bang out of my head a hacky
oh yeah yeah and I said that's not how
this works it doesn't work like what are
the four questions and I know you're not
asking that you're asking really
thoughtful like what is the process
underneath and so I want to share
something that I think I think you might
enjoy right so let's
I asked an innocuous question like kind
of a not something amazing but it's a
curious question so it's authentic ok so
what's happening for me is I'm standing
on the shoulders of the Titans of
research in the field of psychology and
I'll remind you that from our last
conversation just as a as a stopgap here
is that I can't get enough of it like I
can't read enough of it I'm like I love
how complicated the mind is and so all
of the research and reading that I that
goes into it's like what are the
theories where they strong where do they
what are they missing in their in their
approach what are the applied practices
that have been studied around it so I'm
trying I've got all of that that I'm
trying to forget but I need to stand on
those shoulders ok then I'll ask a
question based on a particular paradigm
or theory and then what I'm doing is I'm
just watching and feeling so I feel
myself I gotta get myself out of the way
because if I'm anxious they can pick it
up you know we can smell stress we can
see it in micro expressions and so if if
I'm stressed out right now your natural
response in your brain is to go well if
he stressed maybe I should be stressed
yeah if his brain is picking up
something dangerous maybe there's
something at stake here and I so then
that becomes problematic so I've first
got to get myself out of the way by
being where my feet are right being
curious as opposed to judgmental ask the
question and then without trying to bait
a response or trying to guess where it's
going be in it and then use both silence
and observation to be able to toggle
this is a part I want to share toggle up
or down the amygdala activation so the
amygdala is part of the brain that is
like the emotional kind of fight flight
freeze submission or flow state
responses now that last one is a stroke
you know there's not enough research
around it right now okay so so just
providing enough stress where their
brain lights up but trying to figure out
if we've crossed that threshold where
the brain begins to shut down thinking
clearly and emotional think
clearly becomes compromised because the
emotional center of the brain is too
active so so that is like the art you're
like turning these dials yeah well that
sounds dangerous but no it's more like
I'm not turning them I'm trying to be
the filter like the the receiver of them
and then if I asked just this question
and say it in this kind of way what
happens and as soon as somebody begins
to maybe get angry or break out in a
sweat or find a sense of relaxation or
peace it's like oh look what just
happened and so then we use the
experience in the room to work to
calibrate mm-hmm and when you're when
you're doing that like probing process I
mean part of that I would imagine has to
do with finding a way in like how can I
like what are the what's that what are
the levers here that I can play with to
motivate this person to you know unleash
you know perhaps potential that's hidden
within them and I would imagine you're
gonna come across some levers that would
work but are unhealthy like oh this guy
you know I don't know you know he hates
his dad so I can play with that and I
could get him to you know really you
know I could perhaps get him to a new
level in his whatever his expertise is
but that's ultimately not a sustainable
methodology right I love it you know
okay so one of the thoughts is there's
an assumption that I'm making is that
you hold all of your insights you you
are the container of wisdom as well so
you there's nothing I'm gonna say that
is going to provide wisdom like it's
already inside you we just need to
figure it out everything you need is
already inside you is the basic
assumption and you said like to help
motivate people I don't think so I don't
think that that's I'm not in the right
business to help motivate people because
the folks that I spend time with are
highly driven like the half percenters
in the world driven and so I feel like
not feel I think that part of the
process is to create more space for the
fire to burn more brightly right and
then and then
how do you do that well each thought
this is a hypothesis right thoughts lead
to thought patterns thought patterns
leaves the thought habits once they
become habits or habitual they move just
below for an what's the word I'm looking
for they blue blue they move below the
surface for somewhere I'm looking for it
like efficiency sorry yeah so there's
just like physiological patterns right
so from thoughts or thought patterns to
habits and then once their habit they're
below surface so part of is reminding
them of the habits that they've already
built they've already had great
successes
every human has they've already figured
out how to get out of jams you know
people have done so let's use what's
already below the surface and above the
surface to figure it out now if we
reverse-engineer that each thought
either creates space or tension I'm
gonna oversimplify it right but if that
just with that thought alone if you can
become more aware of your thoughts and
then is this is this particular thought
that you're having right now rich
because you're having thoughts I'm
having thoughts and we're having a
conversation and the better this
conversation goes is a direct
relationship to the amount of thoughts
that are not present mmm right okay so
so every thought that we have is either
creating constriction or expansion and I
learned that from Judson Brewer who's a
beautiful mind in in the contempo of
mindful as research space and it's like
yes that's it that's exactly it
and so that that simple little insight I
think really is how the process works so
walk me through like an example of that
which I mean like you're like I don't
know like in your experience of working
with the people you are obviously not
naming names but is there like I'm
trying to under my school because it
sounds very ephemeral yeah all right
let's go to work
alright so let's talk about I don't know
something that you're working on
building something that you were trying
to figure out what would that be
I'm trying to let's see that's a good
question well I'm trying to figure out
how to create better systems around the
work that I do so that I can be so that
I can do it in a more sustainable way
without being drained so I can approach
my work with enthusiasm and awe and
wonder and excitement okay so where's
the draining come from it comes from I
think it comes from a couple things it
comes from control issues comes from
holding myself to an unreasonable
perfectionist standard and when when you
are like thinking about needing to be
perfect and having a high standard that
way what are those thoughts I think
that's driven by no no what are the
actual thoughts oh the actual thoughts
of the actual thoughts are this isn't
good enough I can make it better
and I can make it better they make it
rich that's the thought that's the
thought that creates so perfection is a
constricting based thought right it
creates tightness both mentally and
physically you probably feel it if we
stayed it there long enough you would be
like yeah I'm all wound up because my
god if I put this product into the world
and it's not good enough I'm gonna be
judged as hard as I'm afraid that no I'm
gonna feel that other people are judging
me as hard as I'm judging myself and it
feels awful when I judge myself at that
standard which is what I do all the time
that's right so that creates
constriction and what that does is it
like it just puts a little sand in the
in the groove right it just doesn't
allow the grease to work quite as well
so that that's simple that's really
simple so then what so then what's the
applied tactic is become more aware of
that thought because that becomes a
thought pattern become as soon as you
grab that thought I have good self
awareness around it and I'm just
paralyzed from actually implementing
changes well we talked about this three
years ago I'm telling you the
implementation is my problem well for
all of us though so you know it's really
cool about this nature of the
conversation me too okay so I I have to
I I grew up super self-critical I came
from a
from an ecosystem from a community that
supported that somehow no one wants
their children to be self-critical you
know well strike the word knowing there
are some families that think that that
is the right way and let me kind of pull
out this conversation for a minute we
have a nine year old and I see the
competitive sport landscape my son is
more on the artistic side right now and
then the sports side or the athletic
side and I see where some parents and
I'm not saying that they're my son's
friends but I just see the the ecosystem
of young parents and young children and
the ones that are screaming on the
sidelines are not the ones that did it
in the pros of course not
no so the ones that have done it in the
pros they're in the corner with their
hat down going god I hope you said
involved yeah of course I mean cuz they
they're fulfilled they're not they're
not living out their childhood fantasy
through some projection on their child
and they know that to really go the game
a mastery with a stop short of that
which would be high performance to
really go to that place it takes a long
time and if if you don't love it you're
not gonna go a long time and if you if
you're let's say let's say high
performances stop 1000 I'm making up how
many tricks thought those stops are on
this train a thousand mastery is like
2,000 right so the the stop of a
thousand most people want to get off
around 250 now because it's so frickin
hard to be deeply focused because when
you're deeply focused you know what you
have to do you have to get out that the
thoughts that create constriction to be
deeply focused in this moment where
we're all things amazing happen high
performance love intimacy vulnerability
all the amazing things happen in the
present moment as you well understand
that of being your friend and listening
to your thinking patterns so we have to
get out all the ones that create
constriction that become noisy so you
think about the signal-to-noise ratio
the signal is where amazing things take
place and it's always found in the
present moment and the noise are the
self-critical thoughts right need to be
perfect there's not any other and the
noise of what others might think of us
those are both noisy so what is the
process of muting the self-critical
yet not okay so it's not a mute right
it's a relationship with it it's a
relationship with legging there's lots
of ways to do this like but it's the
relationship with why am i doing that
okay huh that's interesting
oh look there it is again so it's
increasing the awareness being curious
about why you would choose that thought
and then as soon as and then making a
decision as soon as I do have that
thought what am I gonna do about it
right well I think it's even deeper than
that because at least and just speaking
for myself and I've seen this with other
people these behavior patterns that are
perhaps you know leading us astray can
be part and parcel of our identity and
also what we imagine or project our
crucial aspects of our success equation
so I can easily make the argument for
example that my you know my
perfectionist standard my control issues
that's how I was able to even get here
to this place where I get to sit here
and talk to you and if I let go of that
that's very threatening that's
terrifying right because that means that
I have to come to this decision that
that that is in fact not what's fueling
my success and just coming to that
understanding is difficult and it would
then put me in a place of confusion and
mystery I look yeah okay so what you're
hitting on is big time right it's almost
like what would be a an easy example is
that you know what okay I have a
headache
and so the doc or someone that I trust
told me to take aspirin you take aspirin
for headaches so I get a headache I
don't get headaches that much but not
always action that like metal or wood or
Advil whatever it is right you take you
take something for headache and it works
you're like oh okay good okay and then
at some point you say man I got a
stomachache you going to the dock for
the stomachache and I go you know what
let's do a little test oh you've got
some ulcers how often do you take you
know that the headache medicine well I
take it three times a day no no no
you gotta stop doing this too much but
it works I don't have headaches but now
you have an ulcer so it's a little bit
like this system that got you here and I
see I see this all the system that got
me to a certain phase of my life you get
in this phase of my life has worked but
there's limitations and I see it with
like world-class athletes that say you
know what got me here I've got two gold
medals I've got you know this that and
the other accolades but there's another
space that I need to figure out because
this is no longer working anymore
and so it's like now the question is do
you stop taking the medicine mm-hmm
right because the pattern the initial
pattern was that you had headaches so
now you got to figure out how to not
have ulcers in the and not have
headaches yeah I think that reminds me
of my conversation with Kerri
walsh-jennings
who you know well that idea that like in
the context of athletic performance like
oh the way that you become successful is
you live this monastic life and all you
do is train and then you know as you
grow older life gets more complicated
and if you want to continue in your
career you have to provide the space to
let other things into your experience
and that can be frightening right it's
like no the only way that I can win gold
medals is if I live alone in a hut in
the woods right and then to come into an
understanding that actually you might
even be better if you let go of that
idea that idea may have gotten you to
this place but it's not going to take
you through three more Olympiads it so
well said so there's two components that
we're talking about the the journey of
self-discovery and I'd love to unpack
that a bit and then what we're talking
about right now is a psychological
framework so both our foundation know
foundational sorry both are foundational
to be able to have a strong base to
explore psychological framework really
is how do I understand the world how do
I understand myself how do I make
rational and
a clearer sense of events that take
place in my life and there's three basic
buckets for a psychological framework
that I'm really fascinated by that have
been themed attic one is optimism versus
pessimism and what I found like research
would support this as well there's lots
of good research around optimism and
pessimism not a whole lot about
pessimism but in reference to optimism
and then my personal life experience is
I don't know any and that sounds like a
really big phrase but I don't know any
world-class performers that don't
believe the future is gonna work out
well yeah but our but my first question
is is is that immutable like there are
pessimistic people and there are
optimistic people can you take somebody
who has a victim mentality or a
pessimistic outlook on life and turn
them into an optimist I cannot do it
they need they need to want to do it so
they need to understand like the process
for all of us to change is to feel the
pain of the current situation and this
is why drugs are so gnarly is because
they take away the pain right and and
buying something can take away some pain
you know it can give you some insane
pleasure that may deprive you from that
that pivotal moment in which you are
forced to look at yourself and perhaps
make that change that could make all the
difference it is so I can't help
somebody change right they have to want
to do it my job in many cases to help
them feel pain but even let's let's
let's assume they have that willingness
the answer the clear answer is yes we
are not born as we the leading
hypothesis about optimism pessimism is
are not born we don't come into the
world that way there might be a genetic
predisposition towards anxiety and and
whatever that Woodgate somebody a little
bit closer to pessimism but it's a
learned behavior and so anything that's
learned can be adjusted adopted so the
first is to know that there's options
and part of that process is to recognize
how many of the extraordinary doers in
the world think and they're more
optimistic than pessimistic just by my
experience if we're just taking an end
of one right now and then the the
challenge in this conversation is as
soon as people talk about optimism it
sounds like all the sudden we're going
to get
all of a sudden we're gonna get you know
let's hold hands and let's pick some
flowers together and everything's gonna
work out just right that's not what
optimism is an optimism I think that
optimism is at the center of mental
toughness to have the mental discipline
to be able to stay the course when the
[ __ ] is not going right mmm that's
that's the thing right there
well it's fortitude it takes a
tremendous amount of faith and composure
to say I'm gonna devote like this huge
part of my life to this goal whether
it's professional or athletic or
whatever it is baked into that has to be
some sense that this is going to lead
you in a positive direction right that
things are gonna work out maybe not
exactly as you imagined but that you
know it'll deliver you to a place that's
better than wherever you are at that
moment that's exactly right
okay so then at some point how do you
chip in right how do you really trust
yourself how do you trust that whatever
it is that you're going whatever bet
you're gonna play that it's going to
work out and if it doesn't work out you
have the ability to figure it out okay
so we've got optimism we've got locus of
control and then we've also got grit and
those are three pillars in the in the
psychological framework that I think are
really important to pay attention to so
grit as you know from Angela Duckworth
passion perseverance for long-term goals
control the locus of control like are
you controlling what's a hundred percent
of your control are you working towards
that or caught up in the noise of the
other things that are really important
but you can't control and getting those
three cobble together on a consistent
basis that is that's a nice significant
piece of work to have some durability on
the long play right in life one of the
things that you talk about a lot that is
just one of my favorite subjects is this
idea that we become the stories that we
tell about ourselves those become
predictors of future behavior and
outcomes and I would imagine in the same
way that you know on the scale of
optimism and pessimism that that these
stories are mutable I know they're
mutable
but they're very powerful right so in
your kind of inquiry earlier I was
thinking about some of the stories that
I've historically told myself and a lot
of them are around this idea that you
know I don't think I'm that talented but
I have this huge like work work ethic
capacity I know how to suffer I know I
actually like suffer I like you know I
have like it's all imagined you know and
it plays out as truth but I've been able
to make my way in the world be can
overcome whatever talent deficit gap
that I have because I'm willing to and
capable of out working the next guy and
so I've relied on that story to achieve
certain successes and then I credit that
story as fundamental to that success but
ultimately I see myself moving towards
burnout and these you know having to
confront these control issues in a way
that I'm now realizing it's it's not
only is it not sustainable like it's not
making me happy right and I and I have
this sense that I could be more
productive and I could be happier and
more fruitful if I let go of this
narrative and find a new one cool I mean
that's the that's like if we're swinging
from vines together and you've got
you've got a bead on how this vine is
getting created great momentum for you
and then you grab the next one it's not
quite as sturdy but you know you need to
let go of the one that's really strong
and it's got some good lumps behind it
you know and it's got a good anchor and
lever on it to go to the new one that's
a little less sturdy but you think it's
gonna take you in the right direction
like do you what if you fall you know
can you figure it out and I'm not
looking at you that way I'm saying for
all of us so there is you know rational
emotive therapy is like take a look at
the worst case scenario feel that really
examine the worst case scenario and
oftentimes what happens if you go within
that kind of dark place if you will and
even write it down so or talk about it
with someone that you really trust is
that you end up coming through going
well the chances of that happening are
pretty low because I'm pretty
resourceful but if it did I'd rather go
for it than not go for it you know so
there's something in there that ends up
shopping for people but the thought that
yes can they change a thousand percent
and you go back to the constriction
thoughts or the expansion thoughts you
know when you belly laugh I guess really
good and like it just feels really good
that's space that's expansion in there
and so those thought that lead to the
freedom to have that type of experience
on a regular basis wouldn't you trade a
lot of that for like I don't know
whatever quote-unquote successes
you know outwardly success isn't isn't
that like really valuable yeah and and
and if we follow like Harvard did that
seventy five years study on fulfillment
and that's a long study now seventy five
years right to study fulfillment and
what they found two of them largest
pillars for fulfillment in life is
grokking and wrestling with the
difficult questions in life so not
shying away from this is a difficult
question we're talking about and I think
we had and the other one is deep
relationships it's like Susan date you
know Susan David she's a she's a Harvard
psychologist who wrote this book
emotional agility I do I know yeah yeah
but it's that idea like her saying is
what is it exactly I'm gonna butcher it
but like essentially grappling with
difficult emotions is the price you pay
for a meaningful life this success
equate like the is being fulfilled and
and and and contented in your life
requires you to face these things that
you know kind of our culture pushes up
against and says don't worry about that
or take this pill or you know just
pretend it didn't happen and I think
what what's happening right now if we
kind of map less than a hundred years
back from the Industrial Revolution to
now is that our ancestry at some point
figured out that no machine's going to
take their job so they came home to the
dinner table and they said you know what
no machines taken argent we're gonna
work we're gonna figure not in this
house and so we've been we've been
handed down that work ethic ethos you
and I certainly have but many people
have been handed that down and then what
I think what it's turned into over time
as a generation of the
has muted the store are not muted but um
shifted the story just a little bit is
that I need to do extraordinary things
to be extraordinary
so the thought that I need to do more to
be more I think it's wearing us out yeah
well I definitely bought into that yeah
and so I you're not alone right yeah but
so there's a deep fatigue that will come
from that model in its time for sure
right now I think the timing of it of
this is eloquent that let's flip the
model that we need to be more and let
the doing flow from that place so the be
more be more what be more present be
more authentic be here more often be
more gracious right be more and then
whatever the doing that we want to
experience in life
imagine the output difference one is you
get those moments and joy you increase
maybe the frequency of them and then
what would happen to the doing if they
came from your pure a more pure place
right
that's unchartered territory for me mmm
I've always been the guy who you know
it's ah you know my operating system is
if I didn't if I didn't like really
suffer to create whatever I'm creating
then I didn't work hard enough at it you
know there's more I can I can I can
extract more blood from that stone just
a couple more all-nighters and I can
make it you know point zero zero zero
one percent better you know and it's not
working well it works it's just not it's
not a it's not a sustainable fuel source
right and they're you know we're not
we're not fragile
humans are not fragile we can do
extraordinary things to this frame of
ours and but we do need to refuel yeah
and so you know how long can you go
without sleep you can do it for a little
bit but not too long how long can you go
without water not that long you know
food you go a while so we can do
extraordinary things to our body that
are debilitating are our resources but
that's not that's not that that's not
the big goal right so then what are the
big movers for you like what is it that
you want to do in life that's driving
you into you know I don't know fatigue
I mean I think that that fundamentally
it's it's trying to find ways to provide
the most help that I can to the most
people in the most substantive way the
most meaningful way that's what gets me
excited that's what gets me out of bed
in the morning like I love the training
and all their the race whatever I did
all those but that doing all of that you
know in some bizarre you know alchemy of
the galaxy has put me in this place now
where now I can be a resource for other
people and trying to to be the best at
that that I can possibly be is what I'm
focused on I love the thought you know
walk the talk you know like talk about
it but walk about it and you're talking
about how you want to walk about it you
know you want to live that way whatever
that way is for you that's like sturdy
and nimble all in the same you know way
and I feel like at the same time like so
much of your work is about presence you
know how can you be more in the moment
how can you create that space and and
that you know these conversations are
coming up more and more in my life and
they're transpiring in a cultural moment
in which we've never been more
distracted and the demands on our
attention have never been greater like
you know with these things in our pocket
it's like there's no space there's no
anytime you're waiting in a line you can
easily you know find something to do
your phone and and so you have to
exercise a lot more diligence around
creating that space what we're
outmatched
you know like technology companies that
are really on it have tens to hundreds
of PhDs that really understand the
neurology of behavior the thinking
patterns of you were outmatched yeah you
know this guy
Tristan Harris sure yeah yeah he's doing
a lot of work around them that's right
we're completely outmatched and you know
he's on it he's early in the days of it
and he's going to take on some tech
giants around it and but I will say that
let's say I'm bullish on technology I
think that like yes we need to move in
that direction but knowing that there's
a counterbalance
so I feel the same things that you do
like the draw to the dopamine hit I
check in my phone by trying to catch up
with the onslaught of emails that come
through and yes yes yes at the same time
what I it feels irresponsible to not
carve out enough time to train deep
focus because that's like a multitask
thin slicing you know rip-and-run type
of experience so then the counter
balance needs to be spaced to be able to
condition my mind to be more present to
be more aware of what's actually
happening in the internal ecosystem and
you know you know I'll tell you what for
me at least there's a razor's edge to it
it's frickin hard to be truthful and
honest and the vulnerability even when
nobody else is around to be vulnerable
with oneself is hard and so I X ternal
II I've been fascinated by the razor's
edge that was my early fascination about
sports so working in hostile and rugged
and extreme environments if you will and
what I've also come to value is that
some of the most intense environments
are the ones that we have within just
ourselves you're sitting at home alone
there's nobody nobody at home you could
do whatever you want what are you gonna
do and as the ultimate battleground
right but but like when you create
enough space to listen to that inner
experience that inner dialogue that
intern air ative whatever you want to
call it which is you know it's it's a
human experience you'll learn some stuff
about yourself you don't want to be
reminded of you don't want to remember
that you're a coward
that you're dishonest that you're afraid
that you're gonna be exposed and I'm
checking the list for things that I
don't want to say about me and I'd like
to play the game that those are not me
those are for other people that's me too
now and it's hard because you know what
we want we want to be Noble we want to
be courageous we want to be caring we
want to be great as a human as a doer
and a beer and you know you can't get
there without some real discerning
honesty what is your what do you
consider to be your biggest challenge at
the moment I mean since the last time we
talked your profile is growing your
podcast is growing you're on stage
interviewing pee
full and you're you know counseling
fortune 500 companies and professional
sports teams and Olympians like what is
it that you struggle with that you're
trying to work through in present I mean
it's the same thing you know it's like
no signal-to-noise ratio and so like in
the weeds it's like what are the most
tactical decisions that set a course and
so as a business person making those
decisions with my team is challenging
you know and so that that's part of it
the I know one has to pay me to do
performance like I love it like the
performance psychology and like being a
craftsman I love it that but the there
is a cost to it let's be clear the
reason there's a cost to it because it
pulls me away from other loves you know
it pulls me away from time with my
family and so there is a business model
that's at play but I love it I made a
commitment to never charge a kid again
you know never charge a family structure
again and and so I'm not doing that I'm
kind of laughing cuz I don't have time
at this point you know right but so I
have two clients a month is how I set up
the crafts part of my job that I talked
about earlier but the harder things that
I'm trying to sort out is like the
business decisions that are happening
real time and very quickly that keeping
up with the momentum it feels like we're
running downhill which is a great place
to be but at any given point in time it
feels like I could easily slip skin my
you know elbows leave some blood on the
turf and you know so I wouldn't want to
be anywhere else but those are those are
challenges and then you know even
internally in our business like coach
Carroll and I from the Seattle Seahawks
we've built this business together is
like getting the culture of our business
right is challenging as well you know
we're highly thoughtful and and
ambitious people that have independent
thinkers like how do you get all of our
noses to line up in the same way that's
not easy to them mmm and so what is it
that that you're trying to achieve like
what is the legacy that you aspire to
you know I was gonna ask you the same
question and I asked you first
I know I know
I'll say I'll say it tongue-in-cheek
like one in seven and so one in seven
people would be this amazing idea to to
help
let me start work let me start where
this thought originated so we're working
with a world-class organization and the
CEO of Satya Nadella says this is like
I'd love this for a hundred thousand
people you know and that's like whoa you
know and so we started really small we
incubated small and so the thought going
into that was like okay well how do we
get to one in seven in the organization
and if we can get to seven or I've been
talking I've been like thinking one in
five the first thought was one in five
because everybody has five friends you
know like that thought right and so but
I think the number is probably one in
seven if we really want to have larger
impact outside of one business so let's
just use the 105 for example right now
one in five people in Microsoft then
what about one in five people in another
company what about one in five people on
the west coast of America what about one
in five people in America and what if
what if we could do one in five people
over two continents like would that be
crazy that would be crazy and what is it
that you're trying to do with that one
out of five there's only three things oh
yeah there's only three things that we
can train as humans you trade our craft
our body and our mind and what if one
out of five people we can help increase
the frequency of them living in the
present moment by showing them not just
the value of it but how to train and
condition your mind to manage the noise
to get to the signal more often because
the signal the present moment is where
it's found is where the most
extraordinary experiences in life happen
and so that becomes for me this really
beautiful thought about a pebble in a
pond and if we get that pebble to
resonate in the right way the ripple
effect the relationships that people
have with other people it feels like
it's extraordinary wonderful and you
know there's a business on the back of
that for sure yeah not lost on that but
that that's what we want to do one if I
people show them and hold them
accountable and love them and support
them and challenge them to condition and
train their mind to be
more present the be more to do more I
like how clear you are on that
oh yeah as well he's definitely thought
that through yeah yeah yeah I mean and
that's where the funny mastery podcast
has been like this fun accelerant to it
now in the podcast they're high-level
conversations you know that we don't get
we don't get too deep into the weeds of
how but there are certainly than and we
can talk about today but like there's
certainly some very practical things
that we can all do to set us down that
path a little bit further well one of
the things you talk about a lot is is
the importance of having a philosophy
right like what is your life philosophy
and if you can't articulate that then
there's some work to be done there right
so when I asked you about legacy and you
answered the way that you did so
eloquently is your is is that different
from like if I asked you what your
philosophy is it's similar or no that's
a cool question no so what I described
is not necessarily legacy at all what I
described as a mission so I actually
have a little bit of an aversion to the
thought of legacy because it feels like
to me when I think of the word legacy I
think about what other people will think
about me when I'm gone I don't care
like I'm not motivated or driven by that
and in any shape or form but I do have
this insatiable mission that feels right
for me and my family to go on this
mission together and I'm not alone on
this my wife is like you know like I
mean since I were 16 you know like we
guys have been together forever yeah
like this that's just so and she's got
her path and I've got my path but it's a
commitment that we bank together there's
been lots of sacrifices you know that
we've made together like for 18 years
every Saturday night I was in a sweaty
gym with about a hundred athletes trying
to sort out my craft so that's 18 years
every Saturday night we didn't have date
night mm-hmm like wouldn't an angel you
know like seriously buy crowd thank you
Lisa
you know so so there's that part but
that's so mean for me it feels like a
mission not about a legacy but a
philosophy are the guiding principles
that help me line up my thoughts
my words and my actions to have true
alignment with the mission right so
philosophy is different those are the
principles the mission is like what am i
hungry for and so that those are the two
and and in the mission that just
described you can have a couple missions
they need to hang together you know you
thinking about being a world-class
swimmer and then a world-class pianist
is probably not going to quite work out
in the right way but so I've got a
couple submissions or the way I think
about is like that's my main business
mission I've got I've got a mission as a
relationship based man a spiritual man
as well so but I feel like I'm getting
in the weeds a little bit to insert
right but do you so in thinking about
that like I'm just thinking about how
like that clarity of thought about the
mission works with this idea of of being
rooted in the present like are you
somebody who's like okay here's my
five-year plan and here's how it's gonna
map out or are you somebody who is like
look I trust when I had here's my
philosophy here's my mission and I'm
showing up for it and then I adapt in
the circumstances that present
themselves and I don't stay wed to like
it has to look a certain way a year from
now or five years from now
oh yeah that's a cool thought isn't it
like especially how quickly technology
is changing but I dunno I don't know how
to answer that and I you know my history
well enough that I got out of high
school with not a clue what to do I got
out of my first year of my first college
with a bachelor's degree with not a clue
what to do I dropped out of my master's
of program because it wasn't right I
thought it was gonna be I get out of my
and then I went back to a different
school a different course of study I got
out of that my master's program without
really a clue to do my last semester of
my master's program and the Dean of the
school says Mike everyone else has
signed up for PhD programs what are you
doing and I said I'm good surfing yeah
really you know and I said no no no I'm
not cut out to be a PGs you said you've
got your summa [ __ ] laude what are you
talking about go anywhere you want and
so I don't I don't have this great
ability to say the vision that I'm
setting
by hell or high water that's what's
gonna happen but I do have a sense that
of what the world my world and people
that I care about what their world would
look like if one in five people in our
ecosystems were more deeply connected to
each other in the present moment
like how extraordinary that would be so
I have that thought which is a cool
thought for me that's the vision that
I'm holding to now the tactics to get
there two years ago I didn't think we're
going to have the challenge that we're
having on cascading and and what's the
word I'm looking forward to like the
Cascade like to take the ideas and be
able to spread them across many
different ecosystems so we're trying to
figure out the right technology to do
that as well so I don't have the tactic
like it's gonna be this right but you
know right so that's that's where we are
right now I like it man it's ambitious
but that there's so much heart in that
you know yeah well you know I want to
figure it out yeah you know so okay so
now over to you yeah okay so what what
well you started with legacy you know
and I'm not I'm not critical at all if
you say like no I think about legacy
like I'd like to hear how you think hmm
yeah I don't know that I think about
legacy I think about you know and this
is always evolving for me and it's it
certainly changed even in the years
since I first met you you know I like I
said earlier you know what excites me is
trying to activate people in a positive
way in a real way like in a way that
that can really catalyze significant
sustainable change in them and initially
it began with with diet and you know
through telling my story and helping
people rethink the limits of their own
personal potential but I'm starting to
think of it more broadly and I'm trying
to kind of transcend this like vegan
athlete you know sort of story and the
podcast experience in that this
adventure that I've been on you know
over the last five years I've been
exposed to so many extraordinary people
and and it's given me the opportunity to
be a cypher
for incredible ideas that I think can be
transformative to
and when I kind of take a look at
culture and society like I don't see a
very good picture
you know we're this incredibly
prosperous society but most people are
unhappy
we're overly medicated 70% of us are
obese or overweight or dropping dead
from diabetes and heart disease and
cancer and all of these conditions that
are part and parcel of this modern world
that we live in and it's more than a
malaise it's a it's a it's a cultural
disease and so you know my work and my
mission and my interest stems from
trying to get people to wake up from
whatever waking dream that they're
living in to seize more autonomy over
the direction of their life and it can
begin with food it can begin with
mindfulness it can begin with exercise
there's many points of entry but to the
extent that I can find a way to you know
connect with people that listen to the
podcast or read my books or hear me talk
to activate them to rethink their preset
ideas that are based on social
programming to exercise more domain over
that like that's what I'm interested in
and it's not nearly as eloquent or
well-thought-out as yours but that's
kind of where my head's at no no I
amorphous way so I had the same thought
like okay he's thought about that and
you don't you know it might be fun for
us to do is a project together and and I
okay so I like when people say yeah
that's a cool idea and I love when
people say that's a bad idea cuz I say
yes to a lot like I like to have ideas
so if it's a bad idea please I would
love if you said it's a bad idea okay I
we want the time to waste you know on
just okay ideas okay but what what if
what do we put a little challenge
together and we did a philosophy
challenge and so the word philosophy can
sound daunting it can sound like this
ivory tower experience it's not it's
like what are the guiding prints
and maybe what if we walked both of our
communities through in some way in a
challenge to write down their philosophy
and to do it in a way that maybe in all
the so here's the challenge right and
all the words of your native tongue can
you choose something that's 25 words or
less hopefully less because the litmus
test for us is can you get your
philosophy out in a dark alley under
duress right that's when you know it's
really real and so like can you get it
out and then can you act on it okay so
but what if we could start with the
thinking part and have some sort of
contest or challenge I don't know how to
do this you're better at this and I am
where people submit or do something and
we create a community of people that are
switched on about your idea I like to
activate the wake them up in some sort
of way but they actually do the work to
say what is my philosophy and they write
it down and then and then I don't know I
don't know what to do from there but I
do know that it is a significant I mean
a nice upset that word a few times but
it's a really nice thing to add to the
progressive way of living in when I say
progress I mean it creating as much
space and expansion internal as you can
so you can play so you can be free and I
feel like that's a really significant
way to do it so I love that idea yeah I
think that's cool like how would we do
that I guess I mean you could create
some kind of portal where people could
share these things I sure think in like
a public forum where everybody's well
okay so let's say that twenty thousand
people oh group or something like that I
don't know yeah I really don't know I
mean but I'd like to do this together
and like we'll just walk through what a
philosophy is maybe we'll do it on a
separate conversation and we'll just
fire that up or I send it out people
will like we can send them some sort of
documentation on how to do it or think
about it and I don't I don't want to
have a competition who's the best
philosophy no because it's all gonna
come down to like just getting people to
think about that and practice that I
think could be really power yeah and
then and then and then getting their
loved one or someone they work with get
their philosophy so one of the things
we've done at Microsoft is we've asked
people to write their philosophy down
and then ask the people that they work
with what their philosophy is because
it's born on this idea that if we're
going to go do
difficult things together right to do
the extraordinary is gonna be difficult
there's there's no shortcut to it like
we're gonna meet some rough waters that
we need to lock arms with each other and
when we lock arms we want to keep them
locked when it gets difficult and not
save our own ass and grab you know
unlock dust you know like that's not how
we're gonna move through life into the
you know to the uncharted territory so
it's an accelerant to relationships and
relationships tightly bonded
relationships that are mission minded
and really understand the deeper parts
of what and why we are who we are we
found that to be an accelerant to
performance and that's that's coach
Carroll's model yeah I mean it's got to
be a window into you know how people
think and operate to like when you force
somebody to actually write that down
because we we just we project our ideas
of people onto everybody we meet right
we just we assume they have the same
philosophy we do you know yeah and you
don't know until you're in a sticky
situation and the practice of that
philosophy you know becomes manifest and
you realize oh we're on we're not on the
same page at all that's right and so
there's a lot of assumptions there's a
lot of biases that we have what we're
interpreting behaviors and thoughts and
nonverbal thoughts or nonverbal actions
is that right non verbal nonverbal
actions there's a lot of assumptions we
make so get doing the work ahead of time
is like the front loading the
relationship to be able to go the
distance with each other and so if we
could find something I'd love to do that
yeah well we could talk about it after
this and then maybe in the introductory
part of this or whatever we can leave a
call to action for people at school
which would be cool when you when you
present people with that question I
would imagine there's a lot of people
who've never been asked that question
before and don't even know how to begin
to answer it yeah somebody's listening
to this and they're like yeah I don't
know what my philosophy is well there's
there's a couple ways to get started one
is there's no right and wrong it's an
authentic expression of the principles
that matter most to you so it is it is
born from you that being said there are
easy
examples of philosophies at play in
action and so you we don't have to
reinvent the wheel we can adopt
somebody's philosophy that has been
forged you know and so let's take a look
at spiritual leaders or political
leaders and like what is their
philosophy and the reason you know
someone's philosophy is because across
environments friendly environments the
hostile environments they have
consistency about their thoughts their
words and their actions there's all
decisions and actions derived from that
core that's exactly it
so you know it's easy like think about
Martin Luther King jr. dr. King you know
what you thought about a lot equality
you know his words were about like I
have a dream about men and women being
equality and you know what your actions
were about he went and created rallies
and he created you know environments
where people could activate on equality
that is so that is so clean and crisp
but most people don't have one core idea
that drives them to that extent right
like well I'm interested in lots of
things I think that that's it's the rare
individual who makes one idea of their
mission so so it that so he turned his
philosophy into a mission so his
philosophy was about equality and then
he had some other words that he would
not show right and so let's do let's do
Malcolm X his philosophy was also about
equality but the style in which he went
about it was driving for dramatically
different yeah so so one's not right and
wrong but it's it's gotta be right for
you you know and so if we look at Gandhi
you look at mother Teresa we look at
Rosa Parks you know we look at Helen
Keller we can look you can find
extraordinary people in in the world
Jesus's was very clear love it's pretty
simple right Buddha was pretty simple
you know and I'm reducing like 2,000
years twenty-five hundred year old
religions down to a word that's not fair
but but Buddhism like was loving
kindness like all people are suffering
people suffer so let's act in loving
kindness so the philosophy of loving
kindness is
the core principle right you know so and
I know I'm no I get it I mean I know I
totally follow yeah so there's already
wonderful models but I think it's time
but put your funk on it you know what is
yours mm-hmm and so that that's where
you start listening reading exploring
writing and so come on Michael I don't
have time for that yeah so just tell me
how to hack it I just want to find
mastery come on tell me the five steps
to master it how about I give you your
philosophy to life yeah is that what we
should do yeah yeah I'm sure you get
this so tell me Michael you sit down
with all these high performers like how
do they do it
we're actually talking about it yeah
yeah and they work their ass off and
they recover and they're pretty
principal based most yeah let's talk
about balance mm-hmm we do that the
mythical ridge line of balance yeah
what's your what's your what's your
perspective on the conversation that
swirls around the primacy or irrelevance
of balance in the context of living
authentically and performing your
potential I think balance is so
overrated
you know this concept like a like the
mythical Ridgeline that one day I'll
have balance I don't know anyone that
has balance I don't have balance and so
I think it's way overrated in the
thought that you're supposed to have
balance or that I'm supposed to have
balance creating incredible stress for
me the end of self-judgement yeah
so I say forget about it that's what I
say I say forget about this idea of
balance and work on being present mm-hmm
and so is there a different were like
equanimity like is there a different
word that would capture you're so smart
probably I don't really even know what
that means I like to use it to I don't
know if I know it yeah yeah I think that
maybe but what you know what balance
conjures up is like I've got the right
balance in my life between work between
family life between hobbies between
whatever I don't know anyone that has
that I really don't and so I think the
inoculation the way to inoculate that
thought is to one just kind of square it
up and say is that really what I want
for me that's not what I want what I
want is I want to be I want to be fully
immersed in wherever I am with this
incredible passion that feels right to
me like an inner fire that's alive in
the moment and you know how I know that
that's what I want or one of the things
I want is because when I'm tired or ah
so when I'm fatigued or what I'm fearful
it doesn't come out and that's remember
the story of me surfing mm-hmm that's
what happened when I was so scared about
the what could go wrong this is early on
early days is that I couldn't go to the
place of like that true authentic
expression the creative off access view
of the world to be about it and that's
what you lit up for me in our first
conversation like yeah like I think I
think many of us have that mm-hmm you
know so yeah I mean I don't know I I
feel most alive when I am completely
immersed in something and then because
of that kind of social pressure and the
conventional ideas are round balance
then I start to sense guilt in myself
and then self judgement shame and then
so and then you've got another little
thought that creeps in there which is
man this thing that I'm doing I'm fully
immersed and it better be perfect great
you know like and that's like because I
could be doing this or [ __ ] maybe I
should be doing this and not this you
know psychologists are not funny people
but there's a joke stop shooting on
yourself it smells you know so like that
word should you know that's another
challenge maybe we could do some forts
some sort of fun challenge with your
community about you know dropping the
word should drop an or have to gotta
musta you know dropping those words
because they create something that is
less than hmm and so I should have you
know leaves of residue of not being good
enough mm-hmm
and so I don't know I that's a big oh
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you
oh no no I I just I just say I'd love to
go from thought to action yeah so
getting that kind of thing to actually
happen for people is some of the more
challenging parts I think that's a
missing piece in this podcast adventure
that I've been on there's all the
information but there isn't enough and
there's takeaways and all that good
stuff but there isn't enough action
steps
for you you know I wanted to share this
thought for you is the talk about it
walk about a piece you living the search
of self-discovery the process of
self-discovery and leaving leaving not
leaving living in an authentic way about
it and not having all the answers
because people listen to the oh my god
smart talented good-looking doesn't fill
in the blanks you're gonna look at me
like I'm screwed is the next guy yeah
but so so like just being about it
that's really important and I think that
I realized early on that some folks
would say to me hey can you just show up
at the competition and I didn't
understand it now looking back I
understand it just I just reminded that
no I came them no matter what happens
like it's good I think you're
extraordinary as a human like this is so
much fun what a gift to be able to lay
it on the line and that reminder that I
don't need to be perfect I just would
show up that I didn't I don't know that
that would happen long ago you're doing
that for hundreds of thousands of people
hey we're okay you know like let's keep
learning and growing so just going on
the journey is an incredible you know
imprint on wellness on performance so I
just want to say that out loud for you
so I've appreciate it I appreciate that
man thank you yeah I mean I think look
man I'm just trying to figure it out
like everyone else you know how to mean
me too and and I don't have all the
answers but I can tell you I've learned
a lot over the last five years and I
can't imagine my life without without
this podcast it's been unbelievable the
exposure that it's that it's given me an
audience to all these amazing minds that
are doing incredible things and when you
said earlier like you know hey I'm a fan
of Technology it's like look what
technology allows us to do unfiltered
without any middle person to just
connect with people who you know look we
live in Los Angeles where were you know
amidst a you know a community of all
kinds of different people but you know
there's people all over the world that
listen to your podcast and my podcast
who feel alone in their communities and
and don't have the exposure to some of
these people so it's just it's a gift
and when you talk about getting rid of
the shoulds and the half dues like
that's you know something I learned
early on in recovery is to banish those
and replace them with the get like I get
to do this I get to do this and that's a
very active way of practicing gratitude
bringing gratitude in your life so the
very applied way right so you can say
the concept or the thought and even back
in all the science that would help
support it but until you practice it
it's not real yeah it's just really not
real you know I just I have thought a
solution maybe will dub this in later is
that lets say the philosophy or
something so we're gonna fire up this
thing called live in the tribe so we've
got finding mastery tribe and it's a
group of people that are supporting and
challenging each other and so we're
gonna do live in the tribe it's gonna be
on Facebook but maybe we do something
live you and I and we go on and we prime
people like when this conversation lands
or when you air this conversation and
say in three days six days or whatever
we figured this out together and then
and then we have a conversation live on
the tribe together and then that could
be like whoever blows us away or I don't
know what I don't know I don't know how
to actually rate them because I'm coming
damn bird with all of them they're all
equally good so maybe it's a first
person I don't know what we do you know
or the first person they got five people
to do one with them and so I like that
yeah well that'd be fun that would be
cool yeah well what's really lighting me
up about this whole thing is is just the
idea of moving into this more
action-oriented phase of activating
people you know in a way that you know
there's practices and tools that are
actually available to people that can
move the needle for them I like that so
thank you for that thank you
I think we did it dude how long we've
been going we're an hour and a half
that's good yeah no I was afraid that
you and I were gonna go for like three
hours I was like I'm not gonna be that
guy yes thank you for the time good
thank you man how you feel great
feel good thanks ready to eat I am let's
eat
thanks for coming out so I'm ending this
like it's my podcast but I
I was gonna say if you want to if you
want to connect with Michael he's easier
to find finding mastery comm dotnet
that's right
Michael Gervais on Twitter and Instagram
and the finding mastery podcast wherever
you listen to fine podcasts check it out
and I want to upload this on finally
master as well so check out Rich's
podcasts if you haven't done it make
sure you're connected ritual comm is
that right and again we're all the
podcast players are and your Twitter
handle is at rich roll that's right and
Instagram as well same thing same thing
it's easy when you got a cool name like
that so make sure you check it out and
the inspire conversations are happening
they are beautiful and go back to the
source of like why I even got into space
was because rich created an ecosystem or
it felt wonderful to explore and to do
it in a way that could be authentic so
thank you yeah and and thank you for
deciding to do it and taking it next
level let's go you need to inspire me so
proud to be your friend thank you
alright peace my friend